I am a world record holder for being the oldest woman skydiver in the world.
I don't worry that my carpet is rather threadbare and old as long as I'm skydiving.
But I do get scared,...
...and I used to be so scared that I would drive the car up to the drop zone...
...and think, "I could go back,"...
..."I don't have to stay here," but I knew if I went away, I'd never come back again.
So, the ecstasy was more than the fear.
The first time I jumped out of an airplane, I thought I was gonna die,...
...and as I fell, I thought,  "What a mistake."
"This is death."
I could remember it now,...
...and then the next second, I thought, "Ah! I'm flying!"
Skydiving gives you the most intense, wonderful feeling.
I think sometimes we get pulled down by fear.
We get pulled down by necessity of work and it's a mistake.
But having done skydive, I learned courage.
I learned to go,...
...and that has been the biggest turning point in my life.